من همم قياسيه على ما يبدو صهيب يطلعنا
على هذه التاخيرات وايضا الرحلات التي تم
الغائها اعداد كبيره جلال ومريم والاعداد
تزيد حتى هذه اللحظه نتحدث عن الاف
الرحلات سنتابع التفاصيل مشاهدينا الكرام
تكدست حركه الطيران توقفت تقريبا في
الاجواء الامريكيه كما نشاهد في هذه اخر
صوره اخر تحديثات عمليات الهبوط والاقلاع
توقفت لي خلال ساعتين الماضيتين تحديدا او
خلال ثلاث ساعات تقريبا عندما نتحدث عن
هذه الاجواء الامريكيه حيث تحدثت الطيرات
الامريكيه في الاجواء الامر بدا قبل حوالي
ثلاث ساعات عندما قالت منظمه الطيران
المدني الامريكيه في تغريدتها على تويتر
انها تعمل على استعاده شعار نظام المهمات
الجويه وان هناك عمليات تحقق اصيب النظام
المجال الجوي الوطني وهذا النظام
التنبيهات نوتان هذا النظام اصيب بخلال
هذا النظام الذي نتحدث عنه النظام الذي
يربط ابراج المراقبه بالطائرات خلال
عمليات الاقلاع والهبوط وهذا الامر الذي
العطل الذي احدث هو قطع الاتصال بين هذه
الابراج وبين الطائرات في الجو ما توقف
فيه في هذه الساعات القليله الماضي يتوقفت
عمليات الهبوط والاقلاع مادها كان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايد ان قد قال بان عمليات
الهبوط ستستانف بشكل تدريجي والان نشاهد
الاخبار العاجله بان عمليات الاقلاع ايضا
بدات تعود بشكل تدريج هذا النظام الذي
انقطع ادى حتى هذه اللحظه في الولايات
المتحده الى توقف الى الغاء اكثر من 750
رحله وهذه الارقام تزداد بان هناك وايضا
كان هناك اكثر من 2000 رحله تم الغاءها
خلال هذا اليوم ولكن هذا الحدث الذي تم
الغى حتى هذه اللحظه اكثر من 750 همم رحله
وان هناك تاخير طال اكثر من اربع الاف
و300 رحله وطبيعه الحال هذه الارقام التي
تصل الان ولكنها الى للازدياد ليكون
الرقمين المهمين اليوم هم
4300 رحله تم تاخيرها بسبب الخلل الذي حدث
اليوم واكثر من 750 رحله تم الغاءها حتى
هذه اللحظه مع الاخبار العاجله التي كما
قلنا ترد همم رويدا رويدا بان عمليه
الاقلاع والهبوط بدات تعود وشاهدنا
مراسيلنا بطبيعه الحال في في فادي كان في
المطار وشاهد عمليات بدايه الاقلاع بشكل
تدريجي هذا النظام يحتوي على معلومات
اساسيه للافراد المعنيين برحلات الطيران
اذ يظهر الاوضاع غير الطبيعيه في مكونات
المجال الجوي الامريكي وكذلك الاوضاع
الطبيعيه يحتوي النظام ايضا بالتحديد على
تحديث مباشر للاوضاع الطبيعيه وغير
الطبيعيه كما اذا كانت المجال الجوله
الامريكي وعلى اي تغييرات على المنشات
والخدمات والاجراءات والخطر في المجال
الجوي الامريكي ويستعمل ان يستعمل هذا
النظام لغه خاصه تجعل الاتصال اكثر فعاليه
وسرعه ولدها اداره الطيران الامريكي
نسختامه من هذا النظام واحده مخصصه
للطيران للطيران عفوا والثاني مخصصه
للمطارات وتعمل معا على تحديد المشكلات
الشائعه وافضل ممارسات للخروج من هذه
الازمات على سبيل المثال على التيار
التحقق من مسافه 25 ميل البحري على جانبي
مسار الرحله لضمان العرض الكامل لكل
الطائرات المحلقه في هذا المجال هذا يعني
ان بغياب هذا النظام او تعطل لن يكون
بمقدور الطيار رصد الاخطار التي قد تكون
محيطه به بالتالي هذه هي العمليه التي جرت
اليوم وهذا التطور الذي جرى اليوم رغم
تاكيدات الامريكيه تشير بانه لا يمكن
الجزم بما اذا كان هذا بفعل او هناك خلل
في النظام ولكنك كبير خلال الساعات
القليله الماضيه